جايب الاخر قال وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
حسين امير عبد الله هيام ان القوات
الايرانيه ستواصل بدفاعها عن امن البلاد
بعدما هناك تهديد ياتي من دول الجوار
واضاف في مؤتمر الصحفيين ان ايران افشلت
مؤامره كانت تهدف لاشعار لاشعال حرب
داخليه فيها تنتهي بتقسيم البلاد
[موسيقى]
حرب ارهابيه داخليه وتنتهي بتقسيم ايران
ولقد وصل التداخل الاجنبي في البلاد ثروته
خلال الاسابيع ثمانيه الماضيه وكان لنا
تواصل مع دول الجوار التي توجد على
اراضيها الجماعات الارهابيه وتتحرك
عناصرها باتجاه ايران ولقد نشيط 74 مركزا
ارهابيا في اقليم كردستان العراق ووصلت
الى هناك اسلحه امريكيه واسرائيليه لقد
اجرينا محادثات امنيه مع الحكومه العراقيه
وحكومه اقليم كردستان وتوصلنا الى اتفاقات
قواتنا المسلحه ستواصل الدفاع عن امن
البلاد ما دام هناك تهديد ياتي من دول
الجوار
[موسيقى]